this is like the only only real chance
that
that magnus has because the position
itself still doesn't look
that that good but it's complicated
enough that the time might be a factor
and the last time we checked it was
magnus who was down by two minutes on
the clock with a very comfortable
over four minutes for daniel and our
rook t4 played and i also see the
evaluation bar that we have on our
screen
it gives us an idea that actually uh the
advantage itself though it's there
it's it's still not a winning advantage
you know white still has to show some
technique here
well but this look takes d4 was was a
big blow because it felt like you know
you are opening things up you get some
counter play but after luke takes d for
queen e3 white cemented the structure
white stabilized all the all the center
and okay yeah queen c6 head c6 now he
wants to go queen h1 but also a rook d4
a very nice me
the point was that if black would have
taken the queen on f3 white
took advantage of the pin on the c file
bishop f3 rook d7 knight d7 the rook on
c8 hangs
so taking advantage of that daniel was
able to make the move rook d4
f3 on the board stopping intercepting
this
diagonal but now if black can only get
that bishop from f8 to c5 somehow
but the queen on the c file is pinned as
well
yeah okay queen f2 on the board yes
something like a queen f6
here yeah it does feel like he invites
pieces a little bit i mean just before
the queen is it look like he gets
perfect
harmony and then queen c6 tempo fc look
8
in time trouble anything can happen here
g6 played i mean 93 on the board
black has chances to survive because
okay black black winning this is
is kind of little bit too much but uh
certainly black has some
active active play here
but you know you get such few chances
against the world champion
and if dubois misses this one this could
really come back to haunt him
definitely i mean he he had time yeah it
was not like he suddenly
got a winning opportunity when he was
very long time
it was like a very promising position
with comfortable time
on the clock and queen f6 your queen f6
is played this
opens up white knight i mean black's
knight
heading to bc and another light
light piece light mine or piece might
come to c5
it's uh it's tricky and down to 20
seconds
it's very tricky uh peter queen f6
knight b3 is on the board he he played
g6 before queen f6 also making sure the
white
knight uh went back and now knight g4
hitting the queen not giving it time but
i like the queen on this diagonal
it eyes the b2 pawn keeps things under
control on the king side
and is white has to sidestep the threat
of knight b3
so is he going to go rook d1 he's played
it
how can black [ __ ] black has definitely
managed to build an initiative and look
at this peter look at our evaluation bar
it confirms that in fact black isn't
doing badly at all anymore
h5 is your recommendation here yes some
i want to
to kick this knight away because maybe
for example a move like
knight bc could be answered by luke d60
and magnus plays h5
he kicks the knight away now knight
beast is on the board and
you know now anything can happen even a
black win is
is not out of uh out of the ordinary
and 15 seconds on the clock for dubois
he needs to make a move
really really quick and a complete mess
on the board
he's got an extra exchange with magnus
with all the play suddenly
yeah and three with three seconds on the
clock the move look dc happened
i mean uh if if i would have to put
my money on someone right now i would be
betting on black
to win this game it's it's really such a
crazy position
this is exactly the type of position
very few seconds on the clock
you might be able to hold on for one or
two more moves but
i mean bishop c5 pin how do you react
with
with few seconds on the clock to such
things
but would you be putting would you be
putting your money on black regardless
of who's playing black here peter you
think the position
is that good for black well i mean i
also know that it's magnus yeah
i knew it i knew it yeah magnus is down
to seven seconds himself
so forget everything just look at the
game it's it's out of control
bishop c5
[Music]
i mean this this is this is really
completely crazy now
yeah king
king akin g8 runs into rook takes b b7
this is very important you know
so magnus goes king h6 yeah what a what
a nice trick
that you can then sacrifice your queen
and it's checkmate at the end
stunning yeah and of course uh daniel
finds that and now forcing the king to
eight six and now
rook he went rook d7 so bishop e3 is
is met by is met by what
rocket seven is the point
well i don't know but not after queen
was that meat at that moment because it
was not so easy to spot and
bishop e3 played now so rook 87 king g5
f4 white black still has king f6
but then you've got rook f7 no no i mean
the king is pinna that's
oh that was the point that was the whole
point of queen a1 check
that was the point yeah but i mean still
it it feels luke takes b7 exactly
i mean and that's it this is stunning
this is stunning and the point is that
now bishop f2
f4 king f6 rook f7 was a mate so he had
to go to a cafe
now he just picks up queen e3 yeah now
it's just over it's made finish
yeah oh my god you know that that's how
quickly things
things turn around i mean whoever got
his first
i mean the first punch it was it was
kind of decisive because with few
seconds on the clock
objectivity just doesn't doesn't mean
anything
and we can see magnus just how
disappointed he is because he
knew that despite having a terrible
start and being dead lost
he managed to create his chances and
just when peter you said you're going to
pick black
everything looked great uh daniel dubois
managed to find a beautiful trick
where did that happen exactly yeah well
i just cannot explain why after
luke 4 d3 magnus still had like 25
seconds on the clock so
no reason to panic yet daniel was down
to very few seconds on the clock
why don't you just play the move bishop
c5 which magnus sighting from
1000 times 999 times would have chosen
bishop c5
completely paralyzing white species i
mean look at this pin
just very hard to find to find the move
and uh then it's it's daniel who has i
don't know
five seconds to decide whether he goes
maybe pawn hunting which is not
really a pawn hunt but trying to
disbalance the knight from beasley
instead of this he takes on b2 and
allows this chance of luke d7 but i'm
pretty sure that magnus just
blundered that he cannot go back to g8
and he lied that okay
it's no way this pin is just too deadly
but all of a sudden
rook dd7 and maybe there was some
escape here but i mean with few seconds
on the clock it's
it's practically lost for black and this
was a position which we were looking at
when i said peter after bishop e3 the
whole point was rook 87 let's just have
that you can't win the queen
because of this idea the king is
actually in a kill zone that bishop on
h3
is doing a beautiful job of defending
the king from escaping
which is why magnus had to give a check
move white's king on g2
making sure the f3 pawn is pinned but
was it
was there any way for magnus to defend
against the mate now because now he just
falls into it anyway after rook 87 check
and luke takes b7 yeah that's uh and
this was game over now because there's
just you can't take the queen on f2 it's
met by the same mate with f4
peter you look at the you look at the
final position
and you know that it's daniel who could
only get this game
against uh the world champion yeah but i
mean
again it's it's uh it's it's a little
bit mystical because
i mean magnus is so good with few
seconds on the clock i mean basically
in the previous two also we have
witnessed we have been seeing him in all
this uh
all these banter blitzes and so on
controlling the clock with few seconds
on the clock he was
brilliant and then he falling into such
such a meeting